I got asked a question the other day, I was working with a company.
I was actually, no, it was Nicole working with a company.
I was doing a speech and I was doing some Q and a at the end and a guy asked me,
how do you define character and how do you build it?
And I'd actually never been asked this question before and quite frankly,
I hadn't really thought about it very much. And,
and this guy had to thought about it and I talked to him afterwards and it was
something that he,
it was why he really wanted to hear me talk because he wanted to get my
perspective on this.
And I answered the question like this.
I said, you know, for me,
character is not a very complex thing.
For me.
Character is you do what's right,
you do what's right, you do the right thing. That's what you do.
And if you do the right thing, regardless of what the consequences are,
that that represents character. And so then how do you build character?
It's a beautiful thing because it's the same thing.
If you want to build character, you do the right thing.
You do the right thing for yourself. You do the right thing for your family,
you do the right thing for the people that you know,
you do the right thing for your community.
You do the right thing for your country. That's what you do.
And now on an individual level, those things are hard things often,
right? If those are hard things, you have to make the right decisions.
You have to live a disciplined life. Those build character,
those little things that you do on a daily basis to make yourself better,
to improve your health, to improve your,
your situation in life. You're doing those things. They're hard to do.
And when you do those things,
they build your character and ultimately they lead to your, your,
your character being a good character as opposed to a bad one.
But I'd never been asked that question before and I thought that the simplicity
of it is pretty clear when you think about it. You know,
when you think about the people that you know, you don't.
When I think about the,
the people that I worked for in the military or that work for me upward down the
chain of command. What is it that made them people that, cause you know,
there's bad care. You know, we,
we can't sit here and pretend like everybody that just because you're in the
military, you've got great characters. That's absolutely not true.
But what about those people? And I, you know, I've thought through this in,
in three seconds as this guy asked me this question, you know,
I thought to myself, well,
what about the guys that I know that have good character that I look to and say,
yeah, this, this person I trust, you know, without question,
what kind of person is that? That's the person that you know,
is going to do the right thing all the time, regardless of the consequence.
And a couple of things about that. First of all, it isn't easy.
In fact, usually the right thing is the toughest thing. You know, it's the,
it's the hard decision. The second thing is it doesn't always turn out, um,
for the best when you do the right thing. Lots of times we stumble, you know,
and, and your listeners may think that the three of us, you know, have always,
uh, you know, been on the top of the heap,
but all three of us have fallen short, you know, I mean, uh,
I'll tell you this, uh, languishing in prison camp. The first,
the first month in that prison camp I laid there in, in,
in blood and sweat and tears and uh, and,
and my mental state was just in the tank because I'd given up fighter pilots and
not supposed to give up.
Jim and I weren't trained to surrender and, and my, my mental,
the depression that I had just because of that.
And I think that largely in life, you know,
when you do do the right thing and it doesn't turn out right,
then you have to get up, dust yourself off,
get back in the back in this, in the fray. And that's tough to do.
You know, the last thing you want to do when, when,
when you're getting beat up every from every side and you'd really want to quit,
the last thing you want to do is to, is to stand up and,
and be forceful again to, to, you know,
to take control of the situation.
And yet it's those kinds of challenges in life that build that character,
you know, that really make the difference between, you know,
that the positive life, uh,
the life lived well in those guys and gals that, uh,
that don't make those kinds of decisions.